Jackie we have to talk about the the
Josh of it all that was a surprise I did
not see that coming I can't give you
what you want
give me that feeling that everyone says
you know when you know and I didn't have
that feeling and I tried
every time to have that feeling Marshall
I
can't love you because I'm attracted to
Josh
what changed in your mind from when he
was at the birthday party to having
coffee with him and did you did you not
go to the dress fitting to go have that
coffee date with him I get a little
instigator
that's the way it appears on the show in
the way on the show it appears that it's
like you weren't at the dress fitting
because you were at the coffee date with
Josh yeah so I
I the soup fitting or whatever he was
doing I was actually at the town home
um waiting for waiting for Marshall who
we're doing yeah
gotcha so um I don't know what was it
about Josh that you were like well you
know this dude just shows up and says I
love you let's do it you are like all
right let's give it a shot yeah so first
off hearing his voice at the birthday
party was such a trigger like I
instantly have like a That's So Raven
moment where I'm like oh okay like I'm
having a flashback so obviously like the
birthday party didn't plan out well and
then there was a time where he had
texted me in the morning I was at work
and he just like apologized and he was
just like look like let's do a little
off-camera conversation so
after work I went in had an off-camera
conversation with Josh and it was a very
good riveting moment basically like
really strong and I was kind of just
like okay
that's cool is that relationship still
ongoing or is it a better relationship
than you had with Marshall Mia and John
and
um yeah he hangs out with my family all
the time and bringing my dog Nunu and
everything is good we're together I'm
really stressed out I don't know man
I don't know I I don't think I can do
this honestly I'm really stressed out
stressed out about I'm really stressed
out
this is a lot
Jackie I mean obviously you were one of
the people who had to make kind of a
binary choice between two people that
you were really into
um walk me through that I mean it's
pretty well laid out on the show but
like you know the choice between
Marshall or Josh in the pods what was
the thing that made you say no Marshall
Marshall's the guy for me on this
Marshall
came in and we kind of had like this
conversation and and he had already cut
everybody off off for me and I didn't
cut off Josh yet obviously so we kind of
just had like a conversation and then he
kind of like found out that you know I
still was involved with Josh whatever
happened to the pause between or in the
lounge between those two is you know
men's business
and then coming back into the pods you
know he was just kind of like I handled
it you don't have to deal with that no
more and I was kind of just like okay
and then when he said you know men
handles men Fitness I'm not gonna me as
a woman I'm just gonna you know follow
my man's lead and just kind of be like
okay well if that's what it is and
that's what it is I feel like there
could be a potential for you to be
heartbroken
when you can have it
it doesn't feel good knowing that you
are competing with somebody else for
somebody you love
but I'm hoping I don't lose when it
comes to her so we'll see what happens
for those first few days like with
Marshall I mean it feels like you guys
had a pretty good a pretty good
relationship for a while
me and Marsha
Marsh we're always cracking
happened we were always laughing we were
kind of just like warming up to each
other and it was kind of like I want to
say more of like a a friend relationship
like ruchikian and we're kind of just
like trying to figure out where we stand
and how good of the foundation that we
have so the first couple days of school
I'm not gonna lie when did it become
less cool
because it seems like there was pretty
pivotal conversation that happened off
camera but what were the issues leading
up to that
yeah
um so there was some
and um I kind of took that as my well
you already you know said what you
wanted to say then I'm cool I don't need
to be in this relationship no more and
that's when I was just like all right
I'm gonna go ahead and do me so he would
you felt like he was disrespectful to to
you and that was one of the things that
led to
to this not working out yeah there was
some disrespectful things that had
happened off camera and I was I'm just
the type of woman I'm not
why would you not talk about it on the
show
I didn't want to talk there was half of
the portion about like the whole project
in molding and
um there was a quite very offensive term
that I think that would have said a
group of people and I
kind of didn't want to bring it was
brought up on camera but I'm not sure if
it aired or not do you Chelsea take
Kwame to be your lawfully wedded husband
do you promise to support him in
sickness and in health
enjoy and in sorrow in good times and in
bad do you promise to love him without
distraction and comfort him in times of
distress to grow with him in mind and
spirit to always be open and honest with
him to cherish him for as long as you
both shall live
I do
so Chelsea let's talk about your
relationship because it seemed like once
Kwame was with you it seemed like to be
pretty smooth sailing and am I reading
that right yeah it was I mean we moved
through a lot of spaces you have to you
know figure it out you have to go
through the thought experience you have
to go through Mexico you kind of go
through all these different alternate
realities and then you land back at home
and yeah you know it was a real
um authentic exhilarating and
transformative Journey for the both of
us she loves you dearly and she'll
forever love you and she still loves you
so when the time is right you know when
you come home
should get to meet yeah her
daughter-in-law and I think she's gonna
love Chelsea I believe so too you have a
relationship now with kwame's Mom what
is that like is it good to know that
that relationship is progressing it is
it's progressing it's growing
um we have to give our parents Grace in
this experience and that's one thing
that Tommy and I both have been able to
do with our families and you know it's
going to take time
um but I think we have a very nice start
to our relationship I fell in love with
your beautiful soul in an opportunity
where I didn't get to see you're
absolutely incredibly stunning show
and I just cannot believe that I'm
fortunate enough to stand
across from somebody
who is as captivating as you
what did your family think of of him it
seemed like they were in the show you're
like I don't know my Dad I'm not sure if
he's gonna be on board and then you're
like this is him and he's like yeah okay
great they're they're best friends like
I I don't exist like makeover they watch
soccer he goes to his soccer games he's
his biggest fan I mean next to me yeah
but oh my gosh I was really surprised I
mean of course it's your dad it's your
family this is a very non-praditional
experience
and I want them to you know to respect
me and to respect him and the fact that
I you know took this risk and did this
yeah I mean they seem like really the
only tension and it's not it's not
nothing it's it's there right that was
him relocating I'll be honest I know
Seattle's gonna hate me for this but
like
Seattle you're overpriced
you know what I'm saying like you are
like
you are Lamar Odom with Michael Jordan
prices you're not that great how is he
doing since then that's something that I
never really thought about in the
process of these sort of reality dating
shows is like picking up a life that's
been established and moving it to a new
place that's that's all that's a lot
that's anxiety provoking it's picking up
a life overnight I mean we got married
and moved in overnight together I mean
it is
very very fast there's going to be
growing pains yeah there were moments
where we grieved our old lives we never
went back to our old apartment our old
things I mean we were now building
together yeah and um God blessed him he
never lived with a woman before so we
went through a lot but we're so happy to
have you know have that opportunity off
camera to really work on our foundation
and her footage together
we feel like love is blind or no you
need to need to lay eyes on somebody
before you're gonna commit to a
relationship Love is Blind stop playing
you know it you think so
I already we all know love is blind
foreign